hey guys it's Jonah here so I recently
worked with Nestle bliss yoga drink as
the nutrition coach for their web
reality series to coach the contestants
on the importance of our digestive
system and also to put them through a
series of food-related challenges so if
you want to watch it the episodes be
sure to click on the link in my
description box I had a lot of fun on
set the production C was great the girls
were amazing and I got to speak in my
own native language here's a short clip
just to share with you well done ladies
well done for getting all this food on
the table Jerry and Avila Inga haha whoa
sumo mechana any add alarm' economy and
tinggi de la nutrition the topical
assist empanadas man and a terrible
goose button under tidak akan Department
a nutrition Makana le subpoena here our
digestive system is also known as the
second brain it is at the very center of
our core health so basically what I
shared in the clip is that optimal
digestion is key to a healthier and
fitter body optimal digestive function
means that our body is able to break
down food properly absorbing enough of
the right nutrients and eliminate the
waste that we don't need guys you could
be eating the cleanest most nutrient
rich diet in the world but if your body
isn't digesting properly you will not be
able to absorb all the good nutrients
from the food as a result waste
built up you retain water and your body
would turn excess calorie into fat some
of the most common digestive problems
are related to eating too much processed
food or junks high salt or sugar intake
not eating enough fiber fruits and
vegetables eating large portion in one
sitting and also poor eating habits such
as eating too quickly or skipping meals
so the basic questions to ask yourself
are do you always feel bloated or tired
at the end of a meal do you always feel
lack of energy do you struggle to lose
weight despite cutting back on excess
calories and doing regular exercise
so if you answer yes to two or three
questions it can mean that you might
have a sluggish digestion slow
metabolism and also issue with your
weight so I want to share with you
something that I've shared with the
contestants on the show which is five
foods to promote better digestion and as
a result you will increase in energy
feel less bloated you will start losing
weight more efficiently gain a flatter
tummy and also you will feel much better
from the inside and out the first group
is to eat food containing high
probiotics probiotics are often known as
the good bacteria because they keep your
gut healthy probiotics help move food
through your gut so food which are high
in probiotics include fermented foods
such as kimchi sauerkraut kombucha kefir
pickles miso
tempeh and of course yogurt yogurt is
one of the most widely available
probiotic containing foods but not all
yogurts are equally as beneficial so it
is very important to look for labels
that contain the live and active
cultures still the second group is to
consume food high in fiber I'm sure we
all know this and have been told too
many times to consume foods high in
fiber because it will not only help with
your digestion but it will keep you
fuller for much longer and also help
with weight loss
so this include pretty much all kinds of
vegetables all kinds of fruits grains
such as brown rice multigrain bread
whole wheat pasta barley your legumes
beans and all kinds of nuts and seeds if
however you do suffer from green or
bloating then avoid gas causing food
such as cabbage broccoli beans or
potatoes and the third group is to eat
food high in water water is extremely
important to the metabolic process and
helps move food through the digestive
tract so fiber can't function properly
without water if you consume a diet high
in fiber but lack in your fluid intake
you will still experience indigestion
gas and bloating besides drinking enough
water on a daily basis another great way
to increase your fluid intake is to eat
food high in water more than 90% such as
cucumbers zucchini leafy greens melons
citrus fruits berries tomatoes and
radishes these foods are also known as
high volume low calorie foods because
they can't keep you satisfied through a
low amount of calories so they are
excellent choices especially if your
goal is to cut back on excess calories
and still feel satisfied a lot of us
already know about the importance of
consuming food high in probiotics but we
tend to miss out on the importance of
food containing high prebiotics which
are equally just as important prebiotics
are non digestible or partially
digestible food ingredients that
stimulate the growth of healthy bacteria
in the colon so prebiotics act as food
for probiotics - simply put probiotics
eat prebiotics since fiber is the source
for prebiotics foods which are high in
fiber are typically high in prebiotics
some of the best examples include
asparagus bananas big roots leeks onions
garlic wheat bran artichokes chickpeas
and lentils and the final group you must
eat for a healthy digestion and also for
a flatter tummy is herbs and spices I
always tell my audience that herbs and
spices are the best way to season and
flavor your food without the additional
calories they are also known to
stimulate the production of digestive
enzyme for better food breakdown it can
also boost your metabolism help your
body to burn fat more quickly and also
relieve gas and bloating so some of my
favorites include ginger pepper mint
cinnamon turmeric cumin cayenne pepper
black pepper and cardamom you can add
them into your cooking or make team be
sure to watch my Asian detox tea video
to make them so the
secret to losing weight more efficiently
and to maintain a healthy weight long
term really comes down to your digestive
health if you have a better digestion
you will notice that you will have more
energy
no more bloating no more constipation no
more water retention and also a better
sense of overall well-being so if you
want to shut off the excess weight again
a flatter tummy and feel lighter
be sure to include these five food
groups into your diet if you find this
video to be helpful be sure to like it
and share it as well all the best
you
you